hey Vsauce Michael here a few years ago
in Minneapolis and angry dad stormed
into the retail store Target his
daughter a high schooler had been
receiving coupons in the mail from the
store for things like cribs and diapers
was Target encouraging his daughter a
minor to go out and get pregnant well
the store apologized but a few days
later they heard back from the father he
told them a few things have been going
on in my household I was unaware of my
daughter is due in August I owe you an
apology
you see targets internal algorithms have
been tracking and processing his
daughter's purchases and recently she
had started buying different items than
usual things like certain vitamin
supplements and it sent free soaps and
lotions behaviors the system flagged as
evidence she could be pregnant
thus they sent her the coupons and they
were right without being told
target knew that a girl was pregnant
before her own father
we are tracked and followed digitally
now more than ever before we live in a
world of 24/7 CCTV browser cookies
trackable debit cards and cell phones
and GPS fingerprinting and DNA analysis
but despite all of that every single
year in the United States alone more
than 2,000 people disappear and are
never found again dead or alive
where do missing people go how do they
disappear what if you disappeared and
how do you know you haven't already
disappeared in many cases missing
persons are the victims of unsolved or
unknown crimes they may have suffered
accidents or taken their own lives and
their bodies
are never found or they may be perfectly
fine and have simply escaped their old
life old friends and family old debt and
obligations to start a new life
somewhere else possibly as someone else
how long would it take for people to
notice if you disappeared hmm well think
about it I mean it sort of depends on
who you are how you live and how you
disappeared in most jurisdictions after
about five to seven years if no one has
heard anything from you at all you can
be declared dead in absentia this is
what happened to French astronomer
Guillaume Liu Zhang T in the 18th
century hundreds of people travelled far
and wide to observe the transit of Venus
from different locations on earth they
knew that by comparing their
measurements they could calculate more
accurately than ever before
just how far away the Sun was so Lou
Jean T left Paris in 1764 Pondicherry in
India but after a storm blew him off
course and the British occupied
Pondicherry he was forced to spend the
day of the transit on a boat at sea
which rocked too much for accurate
measurements to be taken now the next
transit would happen in 8 years but
after that the next next transit
wouldn't happen for another hundred
years so he stuck around he didn't
return to Paris instead he built an
observatory and waited when he finally
returned to Paris eleven years after
leaving he found that he had been
declared dead his wife had remarried his
family had plundered his belongings and
his position at the Royal Academy of
Sciences had been given to someone else
he never did see the transit of Venus by
the way on the day that it happened the
sky above him was overcast
we know the human population of Earth
kind of population figures encounters
are only estimations individuals are
best accounted for by real people in
their real lives but that doesn't always
happen earlier this year
Janet veal passed away in her apartment
in Ringwood Hampshire large portions of
her body were eaten by her pet cats
before she was discovered weeks later
and seven years ago Joyce Carol Vincent
was found dead on her sofa in Wood Green
or at least her skeleton was found she
had been dead for at least three years
and no one ever checked on her her
television was still on and four days
after Timothy McVeigh bombed a Federal
Building in Oklahoma City taking 168
lives a severed left leg was found in
the rubble no one knew who it belonged
to
the legs of all the other victims had
been accounted for and no one else had
been reported missing DNA analysis
showed that the leg belonged to Lakeisha
Levy but she had already been buried
with both her legs so they dug up her
corpse she had been buried with someone
else's left leg the legs were swapped
but because her body had been embalmed
DNA in the unknown leg could not be
analyzed to this day no one knows who
that leg belongs to the 160 ninth victim
remains a mystery some conspiracy
theorists argue that the leg may have
belonged to the actual bomber someone
besides Timothy McVeigh who was close
enough to the explosion to be
obliterated completely except for one
leg regardless what it does show is that
it is possible for a person to disappear
without anyone ever ask
where they went sometimes people are
reported dead or missing even when they
aren't premature obituaries are common
many living people already have one on
file
if a famous person dies the media
television newspapers magazines well
they need a full story as soon as
possible so they prepare them ahead of
time locked away leaving only the dates
and circumstances of the death to be
filled in makes sense but it's awkward
when they leaked before the person's
dead in 2003 CNN's website accidentally
carried draft obituaries for living
people that could be accessed it's
embarrassing but for the person reading
their own obituary it's a chance to do
something that most of us never get a
chance to do see how you will be
remembered after you're gone Alfred
Nobel invented dynamite he made a
fortune manufacturing and selling deadly
weapons cannons and armaments in 1888
his brother Ludvig died but many
newspapers mistakenly thought that he
had died and published obituaries for
Alfred Nobel they weren't very
flattering one French paper declared the
merchant of death is dead Nobel read
these obituaries and was so ashamed by
what his legacy apparently was going to
be when he did die he left almost all of
his money to the cause of celebrating
humanity he created the nobel prize
marcus garvey wasn't so lucky the story
goes that after suffering a stroke
newspapers ran premature obituaries that
were critical of him saying he died
broke alone and unpopular shocked by how
negatively he was being remembered
Garvey suffered another stroke while
reading his own obituary and died in
April of 2006 five taylor university
students
died in a tragic car accident another
student survived but was in a coma she
was identified as Laura van Rhine her
friend Whitney sirak wasn't as lucky she
was pronounced dead a thousand people
attended her funeral but over the next
few days as Laura recovered she began
speaking and when asked her name Laura
said my name is Whitney the girls looked
similar it turned out Laura was the one
they had buried later Whitney was
married in the very same church that
years before had held her funeral what
if you are already missing and just
don't know it it's not known how often
hospitals accidentally switch babies at
birth
modern hospital policies make it
unlikely to happen but because we don't
all go out and get maternity and
paternity tests for fun there isn't a
lot of data on the phenomenon but it
does happen it's often discovered
because of DNA tests administered to
resolve child support disputes or in the
case of a 35 year old woman in the
Canary Islands it's because in 2001 an
employee at a story or shopping at
mistakes you for her best friend because
you look exactly like her because she is
your long-lost twin separated from you
since birth and the sister you grew up
with thinking was your twin turns out to
be a biological stranger what if you are
Missy but the authorities don't know
such is the life of the unreported
missing people in a country illegally
people estranged from their family and
friends with no missing person report
ever being filed children of homeless
mothers these people aren't just missing
they are what is known as missing
missing
the FBI's National Crime Information
database contains approximately 50,000
reported missing children but outpost
for hope reports that there are more
than a million children in America who
are missing without anyone knowing
they're missing it is not against the
law to go missing under your own
volition you might have debts to pay or
contracts to honor but if you are an
adult
the act of disappearing is not illegal
in and of itself you have the right to
go missing but believing that no one
would miss you that is ridiculous and
unscientific statistics would suggest
otherwise david wong wrote one of the
most powerful articles i've ever read
there is a lot of information out there
there's even a word for it
info bee city it takes a lifetime to
even experience some of it it's easy to
think that everyone knows everything
that you know but every year more than
100 million new people are born and not
a single one of them is born knowing
that they are made out of atoms or that
black holes are awesome someone needs to
be there to tell them to show them how
many jokes do you hear every day every
week how many jokes do you hear every
year here's a fun thought by considering
average life expectancy and the typical
number of jokes a person hears in a year
David Wong posited a thought ruff in its
approximation but sharp in its essence
if you are under the age of thirty eight
odds are the funniest joke you will ever
hear is a joke you haven't even heard
yet and if you are over the age of
thirty eight odds are you already know a
joke that to more people than you could
ever possibly meet might be the funniest
joke they will ever hear so wherever you
we're glad you're there and as always
thanks for watching